okay good morning and again thank you
for the invitation and I've enjoyed this
discussion so far and look forward to a
full day of exciting discussion just a
word for the sponsor I'm at Brookhaven
National Laboratory which is a
Department of Energy National Laboratory
the Department of Energy is very much
concerned with the ability of the nation
to meet its energy needs and with
constraints that may be placed on that
by external considerations such as
climate change so that's that's our
raison d'etre for the work we do in
trying to understand climate understand
climate change and see what its
implications are I'm not sure that the
Department of Energy listens very much
but they nonetheless support their work
I'm going to be talking about empirical
hope that uh window goes away click on
and share additional features I don't
want the additional features but I'm
going to try and get rid of that box and
see what happens thank you good okay and
so it's it's observational information
that's available to us about Earth's
climate sensitivity and some of the
implications of the uncertainties
they're in and that really requires some
definitions and I was afraid Dan was
going to steal what I had to say or
perhaps hoping that he might and then I
didn't have to go through it but I
really have to go through some algebra
with you folks and so bear with me okay
this is the the heat budget of the
planet h is the heat content of the
planet and any change in heat content
with time will refer to buy this letter
n which is a net flux of heat into the
planet and there's only one place that
energy can come into or out of the
planet from in that space so we have the
Sun that's heating the planet and solar
energy is absorbed and infrared energy
goes at the top and you all
oh this so that the isn't that heat flux
is the difference between what's
absorbed in admitted and for an
unperturbed climate system that we will
ugly note as a steady-state then then
this change in heat content with time is
zero if we apply a forcing we've changed
in some way the amount of outgoing
radiation by putting some more carbon
dioxide an atmosphere that absorbs
radiation and doesn't let it so much get
out the top and we'll call that a
forcing we apply this forcing so the net
heat is initially equal to the forcing
but then the climate system responds in
the climate system responds to
counteract the forcing has been applied
to it and we make a nun Zotz that the
response is proportional to the change
in the global mean surface temperature
represented here by T and that
proportionality coefficient of
sensitivity coefficient called lambda
now we can get into this concept of
equilibrium climate sensitivity I put it
in quotes and I try to put it in quotes
it is not an equilibrium Earth's climate
system is nowhere near an equilibrium
energy is coming in in the shortwave
it's going out in a long way equilibrium
means you have detailed balance and you
have exactly the same amount of energy
flow on equal and opposite on all paths
we do not have an echoer when we use the
term a quelle really must use the term a
quelle heure ok enough on that the
underneath is so here's the equation
that the net heat is equal to the
forcing minus the response coefficient
times the change in temperature and do
some algebra on that and it says the
change in temperature is equal to
forcing minus net heat upon this lambda
when you reach a new steady state
commonly called equilibrium the change
in temperature the the end goes to zero
so you get those delta TS f upon lambda
we call that an equilibrium sensitivity
at times the forcing and then for in
general this s is equal to delta T
equilibrium point forcing and see the
inverse of lambda the unit's oughta be
kelvins degrees Kelvin degrees
centigrade per watt per meter squared
but the intern so again everybody talks
about a co2 doubling so rather than
what I will do for the purposes
presentation what I do in a lot of what
I write as I said kelvins / 3% 3.7 watts
per meter squared to put it in the same
number framework that you people are all
familiar with that assumes that a co2
doubling is 3.7 watts per meter squared
we don't know that number all that well
even that number we don't know all that
well in our community but that's the so
I'll express it as kelvins / 3.7 watts
per square meter okay so how can we then
go about observational e empirically
determining climate sensitivity well
it's very easy you measure the change in
temperature over some period of time you
measure the a change in the heat content
with time you measure the forcing you do
this simple piece of algebra your x 3.7
you're done so you got it that's it okay
so what do we have we have delta T we
know that from observations as 2.78
Kelvin from mid late 19th century sort
of typical and well it says thermometric
records and thermometry was very good
even in the early 1800s but the
distribution globally was not all that
good so again we get from arguably
something like 1860 1880 and take that
as a base and then it would be a measure
the temperature against that but we know
this number two significant figures not
bad okay the heating rate how do you get
that you go out in the ocean you measure
the temperature in the ocean and you do
it enough places enough time and so that
you can get an ocean heat content at a
given time and you do it again later and
you draw a slope between those and you
say that's the heating rate of the ocean
ocean is almost all the heat capacity of
the climate system on time skills of our
interest and time scale becomes very
important um you think about it the the
mass of the atmosphere is equal to the
mass of the first ten meters of ocean
water the heat capacity atmosphere is
equal to the heat capacity the first two
and a half meters of ocean water so
oceans got all the heat capacity and so
we measure the ocean we make a little
bit of correction for other things we
get in so n can be measured forcing
these changing the radiation balance
that we have imposed upon the climate
system is not
well known so what I'm going to do in
throughout this talk is consider forcing
an unknown quantity or a variable
quantity and I'll look at things as a
function of an assumed reigns of forcing
then we can talk about what do we know
about this forcing in order to do this
simple piece of algebra that's all we
need to do okay so here is taking into
account there's 0 point 7 8 the 0 point
35 watts per square meter by which the
ocean is heating the planet is heating
is inferred from ocean calorimetry we
say as a function of this forcing taking
these two numbers into account then I
can say well if the forcing is 3 watts
per square meter I've got us something
like an equilibrium sensitivity of one
kell kelvin per 3.7 watts per square
meter the units that I'm using on the
other hand if this force thing is down
here at 1 i'm up here to a 6 8 10 so
it's very sensitive to this forcing that
we impose on and so what do we know
about the forcing oh here's the a here's
the ar5 estimate of the climate
sensitivity range we've heard
discussions on that earlier and what do
they what does this mean this is the
so-called likely range is the central
sixty-eight percent of the PDF and then
here's the 114 and another 14 16 and 16
sorry on the two ends of that and and
and that's that's what's represented by
by that bar from the IPCC ar5 here's the
climate models that participated in the
seam it five at least those were
available at the time for this analysis
and you see where they're sitting on
here in terms of the forcing and and
their so-called equilibrium sensitivity
I'm forcing this is again from the air
five and a lot of what I'm going to say
now is sort of has to be in the
subjunctive because we say anything here
is best estimates by the community and
then we talk about the IPCC as they know
the IPCC is us I mean we all contribute
to this whether we're on the committee
or not on the committee in terms of our
research we're all doing we're all
contributing to this sort of thing so
here's the forcing by the long-lived
greenhouse gases carbon dioxide methane
nitrous oxide CFC 11 and 12 in that
category and you see even this has has a
kind of a spread on it here's the
comparison with a are for here's again a
situation where something that we
thought was pretty well known up here in
the AR for has gotten larger in terms of
our understanding of the consequences of
that weekend and why is there is that
happening because you put a pulse of co2
in the atmosphere the atmosphere rapidly
adjusted so it's really uncertainty
associated with that rap and adjustment
that's responsible for this there's some
other reasons behind it ok so then
here's this thing called aerosols and
aerosols I don't think the word has been
mentioned it appeared and danced a
couple of dance slides what is an
aerosol an aerosol is a suspension of
small particles and air it's a stable
suspension it's haze it's smoke its
clouds those are all aerosols but in our
business and aerosols doesn't include
clouds those aerosols can modify the
properties at times so it's this urban
smog writ large these particles you have
a residence time in the atmosphere about
a week they get transported order of
thousands of kilometers they reflect or
scatter sunlight you're looking at a
distant object if it's a clear day you
can see it if it's a hazy day you can't
see it mainly because the sunlight
hitting particle particle scattering
light into your eye well some of that
sunlight gets scattered up out of the
atmosphere and and has a cooling effect
on the planet as a consequence that and
you can see that the PDF which is what
slotted here I'm glad the economist's
like PDFs I do to the the PDF that's
that's on it is pretty broad so when you
convolve these two and to get the total
anthropogenic forcing a client so you
got a large range which has got going
down here towards zero net forcing and
up here towards something like four
watts per meter squared net forcing will
look the temperature change that we've
experienced if the net forcing on this
thing is zero that means is that that
you've got a huge sensitivity and
alternatively if the forcing is up here
it means the sensitive he's a lot lower
so that's why so strongly dependent upon
this forcing okay so now i'm putting
that PDF on the chart that I showed you
previously and you can see that this PDF
is so
shown here and then I put the the again
in the ipcc codes the it's very likely
it's likely within this range and it's
very likely within this range so it's
ninety percent of that PDF is within
this lighter shaded and and and and
sixty-eight percent of the PDF is in the
darker shading you can put that on the
same sensitivity chart so here's the
sensitivity plotted as a function that
forcing you can see where these two
things lie and what I the point that I
would make is well point that I would
make is that this likely range of
forcing that we get with the likely
understanding of what with the of
sensitivity that with the likely range
of the forcing is well lower than the
likely range that's associated with the
ipcc came up with in their assessment
and and for that matter well lower than
that always seemed at five climate
models here's a PDF of equilibrium
climate sensitivity taking where did it
come from it came from the PDF of
forcing so I just transform that PDF of
forcing into a PDF of climate
sensitivity for you for you folks so
here's the equity brie insensate here's
the PDF against the equilibrium
sensitivity and you see this is likely
within this range in tonight they only
goes up a little bit more than two and
it goes well below it goes almost down
to this one and well below the center of
gravity of the numbers on the IPCC and
well below the center of gravity the
model so this is observation do I know
that this is right no I have no idea
what's right because I don't know what
the forcing is I'm giving you a very
broad PDF enforcing and I'm taking
ipcc's word for what they think that
they we think that forcing is but is
forcing really in that number no because
we it's a tough number to get ahold of
for a lot of reasons but if i take that
PDF of forcing then this is what i got
you can't tonight you can't dispute it
do we want it it is a very important
paper is a commentary published by Myles
Allen david frame is in science back in
a
7 and they're saying an upper bound on
climate sensitivity become the holy
grail of climate research it's
inherently hard to find it promises
lasting fame and happiness to the finder
but it may not exist and turns out not
to be very useful so they suggest it's
time to call off the quest um why
because we don't live in an equilibrium
world it takes time to get there and so
that's what that's the the thrust of
what they're trying to say in this
commentary um here's a depiction of that
and I think we've seen similar sorts of
pictures earlier in the presentation
this is the the lower chart here is on
two different time scales here's 0 at
250 years and here's zero at to a
thousand years and here's a step
function change enforcing so at x 0 you
impose a forcing on the system and then
up here is climate system response and
I've done this with a two-compartment
model but the two compartment model
really captures what you got in the GCM
so two compartments is great and so yeah
you tune the time constants actually
based on observations and it really
matches up with with any some of the
GCMs the so what you're seeing is here
on this on this time scale of 50 years
this temperature is shown here in the
blue which is the upper compartment the
lower compartments of devotion the upper
compartment is where we live the part of
the of the world it doesn't have a lot
of heat capacity and therefore doesn't
have a lot of time constant that kind of
looks like it's leveling off but if you
were to follow that number over this
period out to a thousand years you'll
slowly be pro qing the so-called
equilibrium sensitivity result that you
would get the lower compartment the
ocean is a heat sink over this whole
period of time of the lower part of the
ocean is colder than the upper part it's
drawing heat from the upper part and
therefore is not letting the upper part
get as warm as it would otherwise get
and that's so that's the physics of the
situation that's a step function for
forcing which is not so realistic a ramp
function is more realistic so here's
your ramp function down here again as a
function of time and here's the change
in temperature over this period of time
and it looks like it's kind of going up
at a slope that's that you'd sort of
expect and in fact if you put the
temperature upon the forcing you say is
is this
constant is kind of leveling out
leveling out near what we would call the
transient sensitivity of the planet and
sort of well below this equilibrium
sensitivity that you would get if you
ran the thing out and Dan mentioned you
got to run these things for thousands of
years largely and certainly and
certainly in this model because of the
time that it takes to distribute that
heat into the ocean oceans mixed very
slowly so so this transient sensitivity
in some sense that's where we live so
transient sensitivity I think advocate
is much more important quantity and
that's sort of the point that frame and
Alan had in that piece so what's the
transient sensitivity well here's what
we saw before a transient sensitive is
even easier you don't you don't subtract
the end from the forcing you got the
same equation and you're back in
business so we now we do this exactly
the same thing and we've got a PDF on
the transient sensitivity a transient
sensitivity is a showing you up again
here same units kelvins / 3.7 watts per
square meter here's one on this thing so
you got that this likely within this
range is actually going below the the
one on that and up to something like the
24 that transient sensitivity which is
in some sense what we and our children
and our grandchildren care about and and
pay attention to it and again comparing
with the models on their transient
sensitivity they are five translating
the equilibrium sensitivity into the
transient sensitivity is well lower than
those numbers that are showing up in the
assessment why do I think that's the
case I think it was the cases that the
aerosol community does its own research
and publishes it in the air assault
chapter the IPCC the modelers started
seven years ago at the end little of AR
for to run their models for the ar5 so
they lag about one cycle in the in the
current understanding of the aerosol
forcing and there are software things
tough to get a handle on okay so um it
could down like an experiment I'm very
nice experiment says okay what happens
if you turn off emissions and so these
two different papers I was hoping ritika
nudie might have been here he was on the
list at some point and
he's done he's thought a lot about this
sort of thing so here's here's from a
paper of his and he says okay at your
2010 i believe it was u-turn u-turn the
co2 emissions emissions to zero and and
hold all the four things constant and an
earlier paper out of the Homburg group
really basically same kind of thing it
is slightly different results why models
have different kinds of sensitivities
different time constants this is a this
is a full GCM this is a simplified
representation of physics that goes on
in GCMs doesn't have all those Wiggles
in it okay so the key here is that
that's holding everything else in the
atmosphere constant what else is it
holding constant it's holding those
arrows host constant but you can't hold
those aerosoles constant where those
aerosols come from those aerosols are
from smog reactions that come from
fossil fuel combustion if you turn off
the faucet the emissions of the co2 by
hypothetically turning off co2 emissions
because you're turning off combustion
then you're going to turn off the
emissions that those aerosols let's
aerosols are really offsetting a lot of
the the warming that we would otherwise
be expecting so it turned off aerosols
at the same time and you get a bump you
get a fairly substantial bump it depends
on your model but what's happens ever
cells have a residents have an
atmosphere a week so a week later two
weeks later three weeks later they're
gone they're not doing their thing the
offset of the global warming from the
co2 and the other greenhouse gases that
are in the atmosphere now whatever
offset there is we don't know how much
there is whatever offset there is we
think it's substantial it's from the
aerosols and a precursor gases that were
emitted last week so we have to
continually renew those aerosols and or
if we don't continually renew those
aerosols as in this calculation you get
this bump where you're getting up to the
transient sensitivity response of these
two different models over a period of
time period ears 100 years of time
period that's what you're getting over
that period of time if you turn off
those aerosols so this leads me to this
kind
except of committed warming and then I
don't think we've heard the term today
but I'll introduce and define it we can
discuss whether the definition is useful
but it assumes the forcing by
short-lived species importantly the
aerosols go to zero we calculate the
committed warming the change in
temperature against a simple formula the
forcing of the greenhouse gases upon the
total forcing is still dependent on that
total force on each I don't know in the
delta T which I dunno so I get a PDF it
looks identical to the PDF that I just
showed you because it is identical I
just changed the scales a little bit but
it basically says hey we got a committed
warming above pre-industrial in this in
this likely range up to one and a half
and maybe somewhat below one we don't
know in the very likely range it goes
perhaps up to two we may be committed to
the two within it with five percent of
the PDF off there to the right so that's
where we are we're committed to that
it's there we're just offsetting it with
the aerosols okay I didn't put up a
conclusion slide but I have a what I'm
calling a for discussion slide is the
global me as Kevin point as the global
mean surface temperature an appropriate
measure of climate change is it
sufficient to other indices of climate
change scale with global mean surface
temperature I think they do the models
tend to say that they do but the for
discussion how much increase this is
this is this is subjective how much
increase of global mean surface
temperature of pre-industrial is
acceptable is the equilibrium
sensitivity so-called important is the
transient sensitivity more relevant what
is the magnitude of forcing that is the
big question that's what we've been
doing our research on over the pass over
a decade okay how much of a bump in
temperature can we expect if we stop
emitting the aerosols in the precursors
today hypothetical we're not going to do
it but hypothetical can we afford to
reduce carbon emissions that's economics
and what is it going to do to our
economy and so forth or can we afford
not to okay and are the current climate
models reliable enough for planning the
missions and and and if not what can
rely on okay just a little bit about the
climate models here's the temperature
change that we've experienced here's
1850 here this new thousand here's a
temperature change that the planet is a
from from ahead croute here's the last
glacial maximum in Mark's point on this
as a that's not so far away metoo
current temperature of about 14 okay
here's the seam it five climate ensemble
and you can see the spread on those is
large compared to this here's this uh
sorry that was the seam of three years
of SEMA five again so the question I
would ask is to what extent those are
reliable ok times up thank you